[Applause]
[Music]
lario pitches outside eldrid the third
trying to find the quarter spins inside
hurdles a Defender picks up the first
down and he's still going John Lee
Eldridge the
third offense first of all they've
really exploited the perimeter when they
wanted the triple option a fake to
Michelle he gets it to Eldridge quickly
and then you wonder if Trey Jenkins is
going to make the play at the sticks he
can't and Eldridge just showing the
desire for the goal line and rambling
for the first down great feet on the
edge and then the
hurdle this guy really playing great him
and Michelle have Michelle on the ins